[Music]
on this episode of travel gear I'm
taking Caroline to explore the coral
reefs of the Bahamas in a personal
submarine and I'm taking Joe to Stingray
City where we're gonna be swimming with
stingrays come join us on our adventures
on this episode of travel bears welcome
to travel Daris I'm Caroline and I'm Joe
and today we're in the Bahamas are made
up of 700 islands all surrounded by
crystal-clear beautiful blue water we've
got to seven different places in the US
and now we're ready to take on the
Bahamas all right Caroline are you ready
for your final clue so ready let's do
this take a deep breath okay that's
exciting
my final adventure I can't wait to do it
take a deep breath it could be something
that has to do with water swimming of
some sort
after Caroline took me clear bottom
kayaking I want to kick it up a notch to
show her the ocean in a brand new way to
rate them up there
all right and do me a favor and take off
your blindfold we're going coral reef
[Music]
[Applause]
I am so excited I love the ocean and I
just can't wait to see the marine life
underwater Wow we can barely see the
island anymore the view is gorgeous so I
feel like if I just keep looking out on
the view and I'll be fine all right
Caroline we are about to go under how
you feeling I feel so good I'm so
excited I don't think I've ever been
this excited before so all right
[Music]
the subsystem has really but one of the
oldest techniques here just like placing
a empty glass upside down into the water
once the air stays trap there'll be no
way for the air to come out unless you
tilt it either to the left or to your
right you just look around see whole
tons of fishes in their group see how
yellowtail snappers by themselves you
have blue tang snappers by ourselves
it's pretty cool down there a very part
about working there it's about showing
the gas and interacting them about the
reef systems showing them other fun
exciting things about the reefs
[Music]
okay Joe from one great adventure to the
next there's more than just fish in the
sea mermaid challenge what we're doing
[Music]
like what is happening this is a
helicopter
[Music]
Joe loves animals but I don't think he's
ever been this close to a stingray
before pretty excited to be honest when
I saw that stingray I noticed the
Stinger part of the stingray it's making
me a little nervous but these guys seem
like the notes' they're doing so I'm
sure it's gonna be really great huge
baby we got the big ones I think we're
gonna get into the water now let's do it
Stingray City is where folks get a
knowledgeable full-on interaction with
stingrays you get a chance to pet see
how they feel and also take great photos
with them in and around the enclosure we
have a ratio of roughly forty females to
one lucky male on average they can get
anywhere between five to five and a half
feet I've seen some girls get up to
about seven feet stingrays when
interacting with folks they love it most
folks upon first contact with the Rays
they're very afraid they're very frantic
first five minutes no one wants to get
in last five minutes no one wants to get
up I feel amazing this is so much fun
it's so peaceful out here these rays are
so cool they're like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what an unforgettable way to end our
trip Joe it's such an amazing time they
were once-in-a-lifetime experiences you
can only do here in the Bahamas all
right Joe it is time for my final rating
what would you give me Caroline I've
never seen you have that much fun in my
entire life you practically jumped into
the water to get into that submarine you
have the time of your life and every
time I drove past it you just had the
biggest smile on your face
you said yourself with one of the best
experiences of your life so for those
reasons obviously you're getting a 5 it
was okay Caroline how'd I do my dear Joe
I know how much you love animals animals
and water that's taking it up a notch
but I think you had such a blast
swimming with the stingrays and for that
I'm giving you 5 out of 5 stars
yeah Hey oh that's great I had the time
of my life you picked some good ones for
me we've been to eight amazing places
it's been such an unforgettable journey
what was your favorite thing we did my
favorite was the mystic hot springs in
Utah the view best I've ever seen
the water was so relaxing I've never
been more chilled in my entire life
my favorite day that we've done was the
one right here at the Bahamas and our
own individual submarines that was so
much fun it was so beautiful down there
and I just loved seeing all the fish so
opposed then I am not kidding it is up
there with Caroline's best days ever Joe
all of these experiences have really
made me want to keep traveling explore
new places and trying new things I've
never done before
Caroline I couldn't have said it better
myself I've had an absolute blast
traveling with you
cheers to that
[Music]